And so now without further
Ado, uh, Sarah McBride,
thank you
on, can you hear me? Thank you so much.
Thank you all for coming
out during your lunch break.
It's wonderful to be here at Google.
My brother in law works in the New York
office, so it's great to be with family.
Uh, my name's Sarah McBride. Uh,
I'm the national press secretary
at the human rights campaign,
the nation's largest LGBTQ
civil rights organization.
I am 27 years old. I'm a
native of Wilmington, Delaware,
a proud graduate of American
University and I'm a transgender woman.
It took me 21 years to muster up the
courage to say those last two words,
transgender woman today,
they are among my proudest identities
and this afternoon I can stand before you
as the person that I am, but of
course I don't have to tell you that.
It hasn't always been that way.
I remember as a child lying in my bed at
night praying that I would wake up the
next day and be myself to just have my
family be proud of me and to still be
able to pursue my dreams.
I was a big reader of history growing
up and in reading the history books,
it became abundantly clear to me,
but no one quite like me
had ever made it very far,
at least no one who
was out and growing up.
It was clear as the sky is blue that
my dreams and my identity or mutually
exclusive.
And so I kept that fact inside.
I told myself that if I could make
it worthwhile for other people,
for me to stay in the closet by making
a difference in this world by making my
family proud,
but those things would somehow
bring me wholeness and completeness.
I think one of the challenges we have
in the fight for trans equality, uh,
differs in the fight for gay equality is
that people who aren't transgender have
a difficult time understanding what it
feels like to have a gender identity that
differs from your sex assigned at birth.
For Straight folks,
they understand generally speaking,
what it's like to love and to lust.
And there's a entry point into
empathizing with gay, lesbian, bisexual,
and queer individuals who
aren't transgender but
because they don't necessarily
have that analogous experience for the
experience of being in the closet as a
trans person,
it becomes a little bit more difficult
and for me and while every journey is
different and every experience is
different for me, being in the closet,
not being seen and affirmed as my whole
self by society felt like a constant
feeling of homesickness,
that unwavering ache in the pit of my
stomach that would only go away when I
could be seen and affirmed as myself
and I'm like home sickness with physical
location which has a dissipates with
time and getting your used to your new
surroundings.
This homesickness would only increase
with distance during my sophomore year in
college after moving down to DC
for my home state of Delaware,
I was elected president of the student
body of American University and it was
through that experience.
It was through advocating on a number
of issues including LGBTQ equality,
that it became clear that the things I
told myself would make me feel whole and
complete.
Making a difference in this world,
but those things would actually fill the
void in my life and at a certain point
that homesickness had become so all
encompassing that my gender identity was a
reality,
was a fact that I thought about every
single waking hour of every single day.
I remember sitting in Church on Christmas
Eve night with my parents listening to
the choir sing and looking
up at the stained glass
windows and just knowing that
I couldn't spend any more time
missing the beauty in this world.
I couldn't spend any more time watching
my life pass by me without fully living
as myself.
And so I didn't waste any time.
I came out to my parents the next day on
Christmas Day in 2011 I kind of ruined
Christmas.
But you know what?
The big present for them
that they were not expecting.
And while my parents
struggled with my news,
while my parents made clear that they
really wished this wasn't the path that we
were on,
that they loved me,
and that they would support
me in every step of the way.
My parents, they, they feared
rejection in every sense of the word.
And we sat down and we talk for the
next several days as they went through a
mourning period,
it sort of felt like I was dying to them.
So I sat down with them and I ask them
every question while simultaneously
listening to their cries and telling
them that there was nothing I could do
about this,
that this was who I am and this was,
these were the steps that I need to take.
And so I answered every question,
mostly beginning with,
are you sure? And I said,
I'm as sure as the fact that I love you.
They asked my dad a progressive,
uh, asked me, he said,
I don't quite understand.
One of the things that I feel like
we've learned is that gender is a social
construct.
And how do you feel a gender identity?
How do you have a deeply held
sense of a gender identity?
If gender's a social construct,
and I told my dad that for me
gender is a lot like language.
Language itself is a social construct.
Every single word has
been created by humankind,
but language expresses very real things.
The feeling of happiness,
that sensation is very real.
The word happiness is a social construct
and just like with gender where there
are an infinite number of ways to express
an individual deeply held sense of
your gender identity with language,
with everyday individual feeling,
there's an infinite number of
ways to express that feeling,
whether it's in the different words you
use for the different construction of
sentences or the nonverbals and gender
in many ways operates the same way.
So these conversations, they could help
my parents intellectualize this news,
but it didn't solve the
fact that they were scared.
But with the courage and confidence that
that my family gave me in May of 2012
during the last day of my term as student
body president at American University,
I announced to the broader
campus community that I was
Sarah and an op Ed in the
Aau student newspaper.
I was very scared and nervous
about the university's response.
This was 2012 it was well before what
Time magazine called the transgender
tipping point and I had seen
the university welcome gay,
lesbian,
and bisexual students pretty seamlessly,
but I wasn't quite sure how they'd
respond to a transgender student,
let alone a transgender
student body president.
And almost immediately after posting
that note and then posting the op Ed,
the messages of love and support began
to come in from students across campus.
And when I was student body president,
I always said that our college campuses
should look like the country we want to
build in 10 or 15 years.
And what was amazing was that on that
night in 2012 Aau was trying to send a
message to the country,
which is that while we may still be
learning about transgender identities,
and while we may not totally
understand transgender experiences,
this is how you respond with love,
with acceptance and with support.
One student commented that the joy on
campus sort of felt like we had just won a
sports championship,
which I don't know how we would know
because a doesn't actually win sports
championships,
but it was just an overkill,
overwhelming sense of joy and love.
And it became abundantly clear to me that
as difficult as it was for me to come
out,
it was relatively easy compared to the
experience of far too many transgender
people across this country,
particularly transgender folks living
at the intersection of multiple
marginalized identities.
And so I wanted to make sure moving
forward that the privileges that I had and
coming out of keeping my family,
of being able to continue at my
school of being safe from violence,
that those would no longer be a privileged
but rather a right guaranteed to
every single person, no matter their
sexual orientation or gender identity.
Because it shouldn't be a
privilege to keep your family.
It shouldn't be a privilege to be able
to keep your job or stay in school
because you come out as transgender.
It shouldn't be a privilege
to be safe from violence.
So I moved back to my home state of
Delaware. I began working with our states,
a quality organization, Equality
Delaware, because at that time,
Delaware was one of a majority of states
in this country that still lacked clear
and explicit protections
from discrimination for, uh,
for transgender people.
And to this day,
a majority of states and the federal
government still lack those same explicit
protections for Lgbtq people more broadly.
And so day in and day out,
we went down to the state legislature
and I started out telling these
legislators about all of the stack stats
and all of the statistics and all of
the facts. But as I watched my parents
connect with these legislators,
I realize that my job wasn't
to offer the most cogent case.
My job was to offer the most compelling
case. And at the end of the day,
stories have the power to make change.
Vulnerability,
I learned was oftentimes is oftentimes
our best path toward justice and equality.
Because vulnerability, it transcends
geography. It transcends ideology,
it transcends race, religion, gender.
Everyone understands what it
feels like to be vulnerable.
Everyone understands what
it feels like to be other,
and everyone understands what
it feels like to be scared.
They don't want that for themselves.
And hopefully they don't
want that for other people.
And so by telling our stories,
it became abundantly clear to these
legislators that behind this national
conversation on transgender rights
are quite simply real people,
people who love and laugh,
hope and dream,
fear and cry just like everyone else.
And when they learned that simple but
radical fact about transgender people,
they could no longer look us in the eye
and deny us the equal protection of the
laws they swore to uphold.
And so in,
in June of 2013 we were able to convince
enough state legislators to pass the
gender identity nondiscrimination act.
And fortunately that night the governor
signed it into law in Delaware.
But like I said, that isn't the reality
in most states across this country.
And so I moved back down to DC to begin
working first at a place called the
center for American progress and now at
the human rights campaign to try to make
sure that the change we've seen in
states like Washington and states like
Delaware,
while there's so much more work to do,
to at least allow other places in this
country to see the change that we've seen
in places like Washington and Delaware.
Now I come to this fight and one of the
most important stories that I share in
my book is the fact that
I come to this fight,
not just as a transgender person,
but also as someone who's loved,
someone who's transgender.
I met my future husband Andy fighting
for equality and we fell in love.
I did myered his extraordinary
courage, optimism, and advocacy.
You was a transgender man about
three years older than me.
After we started dating,
Andy was diagnosed with
cancer and after radiation,
chemo and surgery, and eventually
getting a clean bill of health.
Andy received the news that every single
cancer patient fears his cancer was
back. It had spread, and
for him it was terminal.
After Andy found out that he
didn't have much time left,
he asked me to marry him and
of course the answer was yes.
Three weeks after his terminal diagnosis,
we married on the rooftop of our
apartment building in front of family and
friends,
and then just four days
after that he passed away
and I share that story today and I share
that experience in this book because
knowing and loving Andy
left me profoundly changed.
He taught me how to love and be loved.
He taught me how to live the values.
I fight for it work in my own life,
but more than anything else,
my relationship with Andy underscored for
me that change cannot come fast enough
that every day matters when it comes to
building a world where every person can
live their life to the fullest.
After Andy passed away,
I went through the
different stages of grief.
I went through sadness and disbelief,
and then I eventually landed on anger.
I'm not an angry person.
By nature.
I find petty anger,
the kind of anger that you feel when
you're slighted by a friend or feel under
appreciated to be kind of a waste of time,
and I'm a pretty lazy person,
but that's not the only type of anger
that exists. There's also righteous anger.
The kind of anger that when met with a
mission and hope has throughout history
help change the world.
Andy had had the courage to come out as
his authentic self at a relatively young
age.
He have the courage in college to say
to this world that tells us that who we
are as wrong, that he would
not spend one more day hiding.
He was supposed to have three quarters
of his life as his authentic self,
but because of circumstances outside of
his control, he had less than a quarter.
Some people have even less time than that.
Hope it can be limitless.
Ideas can always be found.
Inspiration is often endless,
but time that is the one resource
and none of us can afford to waste.
Dr. King called it the
fierce urgency of now.
I was angry that society,
that a hateful world,
even with his progressive family and
friends had kept that time and truth away
from Andy that had kept him inside of
himself for what ended up being a majority
of his life.
And it made me more fully realized
that when we ask transgender people,
when we ask any marginalized person,
whether we ask people living in poverty
or women or people of color are those
with disabilities.
When we ask anyone to sit back and
allow a slow conversation to take place
before we grant them opportunity
and treat them with dignity,
we are asking that person to watch their
one life pass by without the respect
and fairness that every person deserves.
This is truly a critical moment in the
fight for trans equality and the fight
for Lgbtq equality.
Over the last year and a
half at the federal level,
we have seen attack after attack
after attack on the Lgbtq community.
Not to get too political,
but the political is personal and this
conversation and just a few months after
taking office, Donald Trump, Mike pence,
Betsy devoss and Jeff sessions rescinded
lifesaving guidance promoting the
protection of transgender students.
They've appointed Antia quality extremist
people who've compared being gay to
pedophilia and called transgender youth.
Part of Satan's plan.
They've appointed people like that to
administration positions and the federal
bench. They've granted a sweeping license
to discriminate to government workers,
federal contractors, and even healthcare
professionals against Lgbtq people,
religious minorities and women,
and of course,
and one of his most shameful moves,
yet in a series of erotic tweets,
although every single one of his tweets,
his erratic,
he targeted transgender troops,
whereas hate by trying to reinstate a
ban on transgender people serving openly
in the military,
which is America's largest employer.
But we also know that the
challenges facing the Trans
Community do not begin and
end with the federal administration.
2017 was the deadliest year on
record for the transgender community.
At least 28 transgender people,
mostly trans women of color were killed.
And while that violence
has been on the rise,
in part because of politicians all
too eager to appeal to the darkest
undercurrents of American
society that hate is not new.
I mentioned that a majority of states
and the federal government still lack
clear protections from discrimination
and employment and housing and public
spaces.
And through it all Lgbtq people are as
diverse as the fabric of this nation.
And for those living at the intersection
of multiple marginalized identities,
those forced to face not just transphobia,
but misogyny and racism,
the stigma, the prejudice,
the discrimination, and yes,
the violence can have
often deadly consequences.
In 2017 we saw over 130 Antia quality
bills introduced in 30 states.
I'm very proud that here in Washington,
you all were able to keep an initiative
off the ballot that would have targeted
transgender people for discrimination
that sent a powerful message across this
country.
That discrimination will
not be tolerated by voters,
by activists,
by people across the state.
But we still have a lot of challenges in
state legislatures across the country.
And the two most frequent
types of bills we're seeing.
The first is legislation that seeks to
utilize religious freedom as a guide,
as to license discrimination.
These bills are coming from the same folks
who are trying to keep people from an
entire religion,
from entering this country.
And yet they're trying to claim that
religious freedom allows them to have a
sphere without LGBTQ people, without
interaction, uh, with Lgbtq people,
religious freedom as a
core and fundamental value.
But religious freedom has always been
a shield against government persecution
for religious minorities.
It has never been and should never
be a sword to inflict harm on people.
The second type of bell we're seeing are
the North Carolina style bathroom bills,
legislation that seeks to
forbid transgender people
from accessing restrooms
consistent with their gender identity.
One of the most frequent questions I
get is why do we hear so much about
bathrooms and this fight
for trans equality?
And the first thing I say is that frankly,
transgender people would rather,
for the most part,
not talk about bathrooms.
We're talking about dignity and equality
and fairness throughout daily life.
But yes,
that includes restrooms.
It's opponents of equality that
keep bringing up restrooms.
And they do it for two reasons.
The first is the knowledge that
bathrooms are politically potent weapons.
Every single battle for
civil and human rights.
Opponents of equality have
sought to center in on bathrooms.
In the conversation, we saw it in the
fight around the civil rights act.
We saw it in response to the push
for the equal rights amendment.
We saw it in the early days
of the gay rights movement.
We saw it in response to the effort to
pass the Americans with disabilities act,
and today we're seeing it in response
to the transgender rights movement and
they understand that everyone feels a
little bit vulnerable and restrooms.
Everyone feels a little bit squeamish and
restrooms and when you can stoke fears,
when you can take advantage of people's
ignorance and lack of understanding of
who transgender people are.
Bathrooms become fertile ground for for
fearmongering and for scare tactics,
but it's also a little bit more insidious
than that why they are focusing on
bathrooms.
The reason is because they understand
that if they lose on every other issue,
if they can win on bathrooms,
if they can legislate or allow for
discrimination to occur in bathrooms,
it becomes the closest thing to a
silver bullet to allowing discrimination
throughout daily life.
Because if you cannot easily and safely
access a restroom that makes sense for
you, it becomes much more difficult
to go to school, to go to work,
to leave your house for more
than two or three hours.
And so these efforts are nothing more
than a thinly veiled attempt to legislate
and pushed transgender
people out of public life.
And we need our allies to understand
that we need folks to understand just how
dangerous this agenda is for
transgender people across this country.
That it's not just an indignity,
which is bad enough.
It's not just allowing discrimination
in one small area of life.
It is nothing more than an effort to push
us back into the shadows and into the
closet.
But we've also seen in response to every
single one of these attacks that when a
politician comes for us, whether
it's Pat McCrory in North Carolina,
whether it's Donald
Trump in the White House,
we have seen that each attack unleashes
a national dialogue that only hope only
serves to open hearts
and change minds further,
and in the end it ends up sewing the seeds
of the destruction of the politics of
hate and the policies that they seek
to implement. We saw at North Carolina,
we're seeing it now nationally,
which is that when our allies stand up,
when diverse LGBTQ voices are heard,
when the business community speaks out,
we can still defeat the
politics of fear and division,
the politics of discrimination
and misinformation.
One of the things that I carry with me
in all of the work that we're doing is
advice that my brother gave me
in the last month of Andy's life.
My brother who's a radiation oncologist
and has watched far too many people pass
away from cancer. He said to me, this
is going to be incredibly difficult,
but take stock in the acts of amazing
grace that you see around you every single
day.
And while it's almost a trite saying,
sort of find the beauty
in even that tragedy,
it was a perspective change that
allowed me to truly find that beauty,
to see that hope only makes sense in
the face of hardship and a witness,
the little miracles that happened
around me every single day.
And it taught me beyond that experience
that all of us can bear witness to acts
of amazing grace that even
in the darkest moments,
even in the most troubling times,
if we look around for it,
we can see acts of courage,
bravery and compassion all around us.
And we're seeing it every day across
this country and the people marching and
the people protesting and folks showing
up in record numbers and special
elections and people standing up against
the politics of hate in ways that we've
never seen before and young people in
Parkland turning tragedy into action.
We're seeing that amazing
grace every single day.
And if there's also one thing we've
seen throughout the movement for Lgbtq
equality and throughout every single
battle for civil and human rights and our
country's history,
it's that change is always possible.
It's not easy.
It doesn't happen inevitably,
but with hard work and compassion,
it is clear that we can make
more tomorrows better than today.
And I get to see that
change every single day.
In my job with HRC when I came
out six years ago is transgender.
It was clear that my dreams and my
identity were mutually exclusive,
and yet today I get to meet
countless young transgender
kids across this country,
young transgender people like Stella,
a 13 year old from just out of Seattle,
who when I met her last year and asked
her what she wants to be when she grows
up, she declared without any hesitation
that she will be the first transgender
president put once seemed so impossible
that we could live our truth and dream
big dreams is now very
real to kids like Stella.
The mere fact that these young Lgbtq
people exist today demonstrates how far
we've come.
But of course,
the fundamental truth remains that no
one in any community is totally equal
until all of us from the
gay Muslim refugee to the
queer undocumented immigrant
to the transgender woman of color
living right here in Seattle until every
single one of us is treated
with dignity and fairness.
But I know that that day
will come and when it does,
when our understanding of we,
the people finally includes all of us,
a young Lgbtq kid will grow up and learn
about these struggles for justice and
equality in their history books and never
have to know what this progress felt
like to all of us because they
will never know anything different.
And that will be because of advocates
and activists who dreamed of a different
world.
It'll be because of Lgbtq people,
marginalized people speaking
out and stepping up.
It'll be because our allies worked with
us to bend the arc of the moral universe
just a little bit more towards justice.
So I want to thank you
all for having me today.
I'd love to answer any questions
and I appreciate you coming for this
conversation.
Thank you all very much.
[inaudible].
So there are several openly trans,
um,
celebrities, I guess you can
say. Ah, we had like Renee Cox,
uh,
um,
Laverne Cox, silver, not sorry.
Um, uh, and uh, Caitlyn Jenner. Um,
very different, very, very
different, very different.
Um, any comment on, on how they, um,
represent the trans community
or it's a good question.
Um, I think Laverne Cox
is an incredible person.
I think Laverne Cox is one of the
best spokespeople that we have for our
community, even though that's not her
job. Her job is, is to be an actor,
but she has taken on the responsibility
that comes with being a trailblazer with
such grace and such compassion and,
and,
and such scale that I am perpetually
thankful for folks like Laverne Cox,
Janet mock, so many
others. Um, Caitlyn Jenner,
uh,
is,
I'm very happy for Caitlyn Jenner.
Um,
I think on the whole,
Caitlyn Jenner is coming out has been
a net positive for the transgender
community because I do think that her
coming out offered a opportunity for
conversations that weren't
happening in far too many places.
One of the best things that
that happened that night,
the Diane Sawyer interview aired was
that every single local ABC station also
after that segment, how to story about
a local transgender person, right?
Not Laverne Cox,
right?
Every single one feature a
transgender person in that community.
And so often we hear from elected
officials, from people. Um,
there aren't any trans people that live
around here. And that's just an absurd,
it's just not true.
Uh,
and so in having that opportunity
to elevate those stories,
to demonstrate the
diversity of our community,
the fact that we are in every single area
of this country, uh, was truly profound.
And I think, you know, there
were, they were, excuse me,
seven year old people in Iowa or in
Arizona who were having conversations
perhaps in perfectly,
but we're having conversations about trans
identities and trans people maybe for
the first time around their
dinner table that night.
And that's how change happens.
Now.
I don't for really one
second, uh, agree with,
uh, Caitlin Jenner's politics and, um,
I would love to have a prolonged debate
with her about that at some point.
Um, but, but I'm, I'm, I'm happy
for her. I think for the most part,
we've got some exceptional folks who
we're serving as, as Laverne Cox says,
this possibility models
for so many young people.
And that's truly incredible that there
is a generation growing up that's living
authentically that can turn on their
television and see folks in television,
in business and politics
for the first time,
not just as themselves, but succeeding
as themselves. And that's lifesaving.
Thank you so much for being here
and telling your story. Of course.
So my sister's transgender and she,
she wants to just be perceived as
female and wants to erase her past.
So I'm wondering what's your,
how do you make sense of your
past and what's it like being out,
being openly accepting of your own
identity? So that's a great question.
Excuse me.
I think one of the most dangerous
narratives I think we have in the Lgbtq
community is that everyone has to be out,
everyone has to be out.
And I think that that is an unfair burden
to place on an already marginalized
community. I think particularly
for transgender people,
when in existing in this world,
if people know they're transgender,
it can oftentimes be an asterisk on
their gender and they know they can't be
fully seen as themselves,
which then causes pain.
I don't want to cause anyone pain
and I don't want to have to go about,
one of the things that
Andy always taught me,
and we actually had this conversation
around out in Antioch Quality Politicians
who were closeted. And Andy said
to me, one, we're not gonna,
we're not gonna open any
one's heart by adding people.
But I'm fighting for a world where every
person can live their gender identity
and sexual orientation
the way they need to.
And that's a principle that
I'm not willing to sacrifice,
so I'm not willing to universalize.
This notion that everyone has
to be out in pursuit of a,
that contradicts that tactic and if my
principal that I'm fighting for is not a
first principle that I'm not
willing to break than what is,
so I think we have to get past this
place where everyone has to be out.
Sharing one story can be
incredibly empowering.
I want to build a world where people
can be seen as trans people and be seen
fully as the gender identity
that they are. Right.
One of the things that I always say is
people write trans woman as one word and
I say, no, it's two words.
My identity as a woman and my
identity as a trans person,
they compliment each other.
They interact with each other,
but they don't negate one another.
They don't change the other
fact about one another.
I'm proud of my transgender identity. I'm
proud of the journey that I've been on.
I think being transgender has made me a
stronger, a more compassionate person.
I think being transgender helped
lead me to find the love of my life.
And I think being transgender has brought
me into a community that is beautiful
and part of the rich diversity of
this country and this world. Um,
and so,
you know,
there are going to be people for me
who aren't willing to see me as a woman
because I'm also out as trans.
And I'm fortunate to have,
I think privileges that allow,
that shield me from the consequences
of those stigmas and biases.
It doesn't bother me either.
Um,
at the end of the day it doesn't cause
me pain anymore. It may be used to. Um,
but for those who would experience pain,
I would never want to say to them,
well,
you have to go through even
more for a political end.
Even if that political
and his moral imperative,
I'm not willing to require
someone to live their life,
to watch their life pass
by or to experience more
pain in their one life, uh,
for this movement. There are so many
other ways that we can achieve a quality.
So those are sort of my individual
feelings about me being out,
but also my feelings more broadly about
not requiring other people who are Lgbtq
to be out.
So the,
the human rights campaign is not have
the best track record for trends,
advocacy. Uh, for example,
there's the scorecard for
lots of large companies,
um, that will mark 100%
this, this company is,
is great for Lgbtq folks
and their, their, uh,
medical insurance will be,
we'll have trans exclusion clauses
and if they can't get a hundred,
if they're, if they have
exclusion clauses, that's,
that's that that has changed.
That has changed now.
Sorry,
if you want to finish your question and
I can respond to, to all of it. Right.
I was sorry. I was just asking,
um, that now that you're with HRC,
what positive changes have
you seen in that organization?
So that's a great question I think,
and I appreciate you,
you asking that question. Um, so the
first on the, on the question of the Cei,
um, there is a requirement
in the, that companies have,
don't have exclusions that companies
have inclusive health insurance. Now,
that doesn't always
mean that every single,
unfortunately health insurance plan is
going to cover the full range of services
and procedures that
transgender people need.
And that's an ongoing conversation
that we continue to work with insurance
providers on ensuring that their standards
are truly inclusive of the medical
needs of the transgender community.
Um,
but the CEI does require trans
inclusive health benefits.
And actually we've seen in
the several years since the,
that aspect has been included in the
CEI and because of so many people within
companies articulating and
advocating for change. Um,
but we've seen that the percentage of
major companies that are scored by the Cei
that have trans inclusive health insurance
or don't have exclusions at the very
least has gone from single
digits, percentage wise to
60 something percent. Um,
so, so on that front, um,
the Cei, uh, I think has,
is,
is always evolving and always constantly
looking at what are best practices and
best practices, rightfully, are always
evolving and changing and improving. Uh,
but on the specific question of health
insurance we do, we do require that, um,
uh, or one of the major elements of
scoring is that there aren't exclusions,
um, more broadly. So I'll, you know,
I'll be up front about this history for
folks that don't have quite the same
context.
In 2007,
the human rights campaign continued to
support the employment non discrimination
act even after gender identity was
stripped out by Democrats in the House of
Representatives. And that was a decision
that was wrong. Plain and simple.
I don't think there's anyone at the
organization that would make that same
decision twice.
The organization's new leadership,
Chad Griffin has apologized for that.
We have a principal that will,
that is unbreakable,
that we will never support legislation
that is not inclusive of gender identity.
Um,
and um,
and one of the things that
I truly appreciate about my
colleagues at HRC is they
understand that that was a decision that
left real scars for a lot of people.
And that changes in perceptions and that
people healing from that pain and that
wound doesn't,
that healing doesn't happen overnight.
That it takes time.
And one of the things that I
really value about my colleagues,
both trans and CIS, CIS gender is a
term for people who aren't transgender,
is that they understand that even though
there is a ton of great work happening
at the Human Rights Campaign
Today on Trans issues,
that it's going to require that sustained
investment before people are willing
to, to forgive. And frankly they'll,
they'll, they'll never forget, um,
that those scars are
deep and they're lasting.
What are some of the things and some
of the work that I see right now in the
human rights campaign on Trans Issues,
first I wouldn't go to an organization
that I wasn't totally positive,
was 150% behind,
passionate about and centering trans
equality work in their work. Um,
before I was on staff at HRC I
talked about the gender identity non
discrimination bill in Delaware,
and I can tell you without any question
in my mind is the person who helped lead
that effort and Delaware that we would
have not passed that bill without HRC.
HRC came in with resources. They came in
with staff, they came in with expertise,
they came in with skill,
they came in with mobilization efforts
that truly allowed us to pass both
marriage equality and gender identity
protections within a month of each other,
which is historic. And, and I saw
that passion. I saw that skill.
I saw that commitment from the
staff, from Chad Griffin on down. Uh,
and I, I have seen firsthand and been
the beneficiary firsthand of that work.
Um,
the organization is always,
every organization is always
on a path for growth, right?
No organization is perfect.
There's always more that can be done.
But in terms of the Progress I've
seen over the last several years,
trans work is probably 60 to 70%
of our work at this point. Um,
trans work is not just as
the center of the movement,
but it's at the center of the work
that we do every day. Um, you know,
we put on precedent on an
unprecedented amount of staff,
volunteers,
uh,
and money into the state of North Carolina
to specifically defeat Pat McCrory
after HB two.
Uh,
because we understood that defeating
Pat McCrory would send an a really
important message to Andrea quality
politicians that if you come for us,
we're going to come for you,
not just the Trans Committee but the
Lgbtq community and our allies will come
for you on election day.
Um,
I see the amazing trans work that's
happening in our foundation programs,
which is working to ensure that our
schools are inclusive of trans and gender
nonconforming nonbinary and
gender expansive students.
Making sure that our hospitals
are becoming a bit more safer.
As someone who's been a caregiver and a
patient in a hospital, as a trans person,
I know just how important that is and
how much work there remains to be done.
So we have a team that's
working specifically on
expanding hospital a safety and
access and a lot of their
work is trans focused. Um,
at the state level. For instance,
there was a battle in Pennsylvania.
We removed our support for a bill,
a nondiscrimination bill,
not that that still
included gender identity,
but they stripped out
public accommodations and
we knew that stripping out
public accommodations
would disproportionately
harm the Trans con change
transgender community. And so we said
we can no longer support this bill.
And the bill died in part because of us
and other organizations saying this is a
first principle.
Any legislation that disproportionately
does not protect the trans community is
legislation. We can't support. Um,
we're hiring more trans staffers.
I think the diversity on our staff,
both in terms of gender
identity and trans identities,
but also in terms of race and religion,
immigration status,
all of these different identities
that make up a diverse workforce, uh,
that were consistent consistently trying
to make sure that we're hiring more
diverse staff, more trans and
gender nonconforming people,
not just in entry level positions,
but also in senior leadership positions,
public positions and communications and
the foundation and our legal team. Um,
so I've seen a lot of progress.
I'm really passionate about the work that
we're doing and the fact that I didn't
join an organization because
I wanted to come in and, and,
and try to make it start doing trans work.
I came into this organization because
I saw firsthand just how much they were
doing and just how skillfully they
were doing it. Thank you. Thank you.
First of all, thank you so, so much. I
have had a cough for like four weeks,
so I apologize.
Uh, so my question is, I like, no,
and I know of a lot of people whose
opinions on Trans people are like pretty
uninformed by actual interactions with
or hearing the stories of trans people
that are often,
you know,
very sort of biological essential
list or very rooted in sort of data,
gender theory. Um, and I was
wondering how you interact with, uh,
people like that.
People who may not even think that
they know any trans people without like
taking the whole burden on yourself to
try to humanize yourself or make this
about like to try to like convince them
that trans people are real and people,
so that's a great question. Um, I,
I think in terms of how do I deal with it,
I feel a particular responsibility to
deal with that and I feel a particular
responsibility and the fact that
I, I, this is my job to, um,
uh,
to be willing to,
to bear a bit more of that burden
of humanizing and educating.
I think there are a couple things.
One,
there are certain things that I am from
about that I'm not going to talk about,
right. My personal medical history,
it's just that it's personal. Um,
and I am
pretty clear,
particularly for a reporter
asks me about that,
that like I politely push back
and just say, you know, I'm sorry,
I'm not comfortable talking about that.
Certainly not all on the record. Um,
you know,
there are some people who aren't going
to change their mind either ever or in
one sitting.
And I think understanding that and,
and sort of freeing myself from that
responsibility of feeling like if I don't
change everyone from, you
know, a to z in one sitting,
then I've failed or I'm
not doing a good job. Um,
I think that's been been freeing
in many ways. My approach is this.
I know that there are, there's a lot of
ignorance out there. I know I want my,
I want allies to educate themselves,
but I understand that like,
it's also difficult to not
know what you don't know.
And so people are going to make mistakes.
People are going to come in
with knowledge gaps that exist.
If you're coming to me
with a genuine interest,
a genuine desire to understand
if there's a willingness to grow,
if there's a willingness
to not get defensive,
if you make a mistake and
I politely correct you,
then I'll sit and I will engage.
If there's no willingness,
then they can come back to me when
they may be grow the heart that they're
lacking in that moment. Um, so I think,
and I think for the most part,
most people are in that, um,
in that,
in that former category,
I think most people are
compassionate people.
Most people are empathetic people that
when confronted with a human being in
front of them,
when confronted with a story,
their hearts will be opened. Their
mind, their minds will be changing,
their hearts will be open at least
a little bit. And you know I,
and so I think that, wow, I'm not,
don't need to spend my
time with someone who's,
who's doing this just to troll or just a
hurt that the vast majority of people I
can engage with because they are,
they're coming to me with a genuine
willingness to have their empathy tapped.
And, and I think that at the
end of the day, if we do that,
if we allow ourselves to do that,
and if we allow people to make mistakes
but offer people the willingness to grow
and the opportunity to grow that,
that will make progress.
Hi. Hello. I'm, I'm also
from Wilmington, Delaware,
and I'm also a trans woman and we have
like family connections actually people
that I grew up with it no, your
family. Yeah. Can I ask you? Yeah.
So your brother is best friends with my
cousin Philip Lahm Plo. Yeah. Oh my God.
Yeah. Delaware is truly so
every time not tell her,
you're like, oh my God. Do you remember
chocolate pit? Maybe they're dated,
made it or relate. Exactly. Exactly.
So I was in a trans activism here.
I'm a founder of Gender Justice League.
I'm for Washington state. I Love Gender
Justice League. You, we love you.
And I was part of the effort,
uh,
in front of the Senate to get the bathroom
bill shut down a couple of years ago.
And I have since stopped doing activism
because it's exhausting and draining and
it,
it will eat your life.
And My masochism has led me to the dregs
of the Internet and to get my anger
out.
And so I was,
I see a lot of direct misinformation
campaigns like intentional structured
toxification of communities.
I see things like Prager u and you know,
Jordan Peterson and these people that
come out with this sort of low level soft
sell this information for the hard right.
And I wonder how aware slash concerned
are people or places like the HRC,
which I know you guys have legislation
as sort of your main deal. And,
okay.
When it comes to social
communities on the Internet,
like Reddit or youtube comments sections,
where do you guys feel like
the responsibility lies
to make sure that these
platforms aren't used specifically?
Um,
to spread this disinformation
and to sort of weaponize
awful? Yeah. Um,
so to the first question of sort
of how aware and concerned are,
we are very aware and actively
engaged on the issue. Um,
one of the things that, that we
have tried to do is, uh, you know,
there are a handful of,
um,
while the vast majority of the medical
community and scientific community affirm
the reality and of transgender people
on the need to have access to affirming
healthcare and affirm
transgender gender identities,
the validity of transgender identities.
There are a handful.
There's always plenty of like
home waiting in the background.
Paul McHugh is a great example. Um,
we have done a lot to try to engage,
um, educate the media, uh,
to get statements of opposition from
their research institutions if they're
affiliated with research institutions,
articulating that these positions are
not the positions of this institution,
that this institution,
you know,
Johns Hopkins is a great example with
Makiah was a hospital too that my husband
went to as a cancer patient.
And every single time we got a new
doctor or a nurse, we would wonder,
is this person familiar with Paul Mchugh?
Are they an Acolyte of Paul Mchugh?
And will that change the way they interact
with Andy and me because of that. Um,
and so we've actually spent the last
two years trying to engage with Johns
Hopkins to get them to make
a clear affirmative statement
that Paul McHugh does
not represent the positions of the
hospital and the institution. Um,
because those are important statements
to be able to combat the misinformation
that Paul Mchugh, who's not a
gender or sexuality specialist,
but who has these personal biases that
he writes about a nonscientific journals.
But with a doctor in front of his name.
That makes it seem like he has
credibility on the issue. Um,
to make sure that we get these statements
that we can have them ready in courts
if he's ever testify and legislatures,
if he's ever testifying.
And to again educate the, the, the,
the media about why this person
is not a credible person to be,
to be interviewing on trans identities.
Um,
so we're very aware of that. There's
ongoing efforts depending, uh, Bailey,
I think Jay, Michael Bailey.
Yeah. There, there's a whole host,
there's a wonderful person named Brent
Hannah Hill who does a lot of writing on
Brynne's great.
And we work actively with Bren tracking
these folks and making sure that we're
going in and engaging with
their institutions. Um, the,
the second question of
like the responsibility of
platforms to make sure that
social media and the Internet is a
force for good as opposed to, um,
you know, a force that Aleks, the 45th
president of the United States, um,
is I think one of the most
significant questions before us.
How do we,
how do we leverage changing and advancing
technologies for good and not for ill?
How do we address the reality also that
in this individualized media society,
half of the country is truly
not even hearing the other half.
How do we bridge that divide,
whether it's in cable news,
whether it's an f on Facebook,
whether it's on social media,
where people are going into these echo
chambers and if you're going into an echo
chamber of hate it emboldens or heat.
Um,
I don't have a good answer, right?
That's honestly above my pay grade.
In terms of like what sort of,
what are the mechanisms that
these individual platforms should,
uh, utilize or what steps
should they take to address it?
I do think they have a moral,
a moral obligation,
a business obligation and a practical
obligation to make sure that they are
truly rooting out hate
speech when it occurs at,
in violent speech when it
occurs on their platforms.
If they have these policies they
need to actually abide by them. Um,
I think they need to make sure that,
um,
that if they don't have those policies
that are adopting those policies for one,
I think one of the exciting things
that we're seeing right now is that the
generation just behind me,
I'm a millennial generation,
that's sort of our digital natives are, I
think, I don't, I think they're doing it.
I don't think they know
how they're doing it,
but I think they're already doing it
where they're bridging that divide that
exists across media and,
um,
they're utilizing social
media for good. Um, and,
and I think that's going to be the
generation that truly figures out how we
solve what feels almost like an
unsolvable problem at this point. Um,
I know the obligations exist, but I
don't have answers for them. Um, and,
and I would certainly charge anyone
who's working in tech to actively grapple
with these questions to actively grapple
with the policies you have and the
practices that are occurring.
Um,
because I truly think it's probably
the biggest question we face.
Both. They use both the echoing of hate
on social media that emboldens hate.
And also this divide that no longer
allows us to operate from the,
from from the same fact patterns and
the same conversations and keep us from
talking with one another. So it's a great
question. I don't have a good answer. No,
that's fine. I'm passionate about it
and I think we need to address it. Okay,
great. Great. Thank you so
much, Sarah, for coming today,
sharing your story.